[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale à ryder cup au
programme aujourd'hui les premiers
entraînements et le match des célébrités
[Musique]
les joueurs américains et européens sont
arrivés hier soir au trianon palace de
versailles et ils sont arrivés dès
aujourd'hui sur les greens pour
s'entraîner 10 sessions découvertes pour
les golfeurs européens et américains
tout juste arrivé la veille les sportifs
se sont retrouvés pour la première fois
sur les greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce mardi 25
septembre objectif de cette journée
créée avant tout une cohésion d'équipé
ce matin c'est un peu
décrassage pour les joueurs ils ont un
petit jet lag
ils sont arrivés hier ils sont un peu
excité donc aujourd'hui c'est le joie je
pense le la bonne humeur de se
rencontrer se mettent ensemble ce matin
très tôt
mon bureau est juste à côté de la salle
d' équipes d'europe
il y avait de l'ambiance les deux
équipes ont également eu l'occasion
d'observer l'effervescence autour de
cette 42e ryder cup en france
ils étaient plus de 20 mille aujourd'hui
sur le parcours du golf national pour
venir soutenir leurs protégés et
certains supporters européens n'ont pas
hésité à sortir les déguisements dès le
premier jour là c'est juste le début est
normalement là on a tout un groupe
d'amis qui arrivent de berlin exprès
pour ça et on va bien sortir les
chapeaux et ses partenaires dès les
premières heures pour les mettre en
confiance pour pour savoir au moins ils
savent que s'ils sont en europe
ils sont chez eux et que derrière il ya
public et également parce que le public
compte énormément pour une ryder les
deux équipes s'entraîneront de nouveau
demain dans la journée devant le public
de saint quentin en yvelines à côté à
des entraînements officiels il ya le
fameux match des célébrités
le concept douze célébrités américaines
affronte douze célébrités européenne du
côté à des américains on notera la
présence de samuel l jackson qui est
juste derrière marc ou encore du nageur
michael phelps
du côté à des européens on notera la
présence du français à dany boon c'est
un sport très exigeant et où il faut
savoir faire preuve de beaucoup
d'humilité
si je joue je suis 8 de handicap peu
près 8 donc c'est un peu flippant quand
même
[Musique]
c'est important d'être là aujourd'hui
demain et toute la semaine jusqu'à
dimanche pour soutenir l'équipe
européenne soutenir le golf national le
golf français
nous avons besoin de nous entraîner mais
j'espère gagner mon niveau de golf et je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas encore
heureux heureux nerveux nerveux quand
ouais bah c'est voir jouer ici c'est
quand même c'est pas rien c'est pas
banal
voilà quelques jours de la rider sur le
parcours voilà c'est un luxe à fil au
caire je me sens bien je me sens plutôt
calme aujourd'hui je suis bien pour le
moment mais sur le premier trou je pense
que je ne serai pas se rend cette
première journée de ryder cup c'est
aussi à l'occasion d'entendre ici en
conférence de presse les golfeurs
européens et les golfeurs américains
et bien sûr on a laissé tendre l'oreille
du côté de thaïlande
hier soir c'était sympa il simplement de
passer la soirée avec mes coéquipiers
avec tout le staff
et puis aujourd'hui bon c'était bien de
se détendre de se dégourdir les jambes
prendre un bon bol d'air et jouer au
golf
notre image du jour elle est dédiée aux
jardiniers ils sont à 180 sur le
parcours pendant la ryder cup
imaginez vous à 10 par trou et ils
viennent du monde entier on écoute
philippines a tôt à ce sujet je pense
que là on peut faire que on ne peut que
s'incliner devant le travail qu'ils ont
fait qui est engagée depuis maintenant
de nombreuses années un cirque le
résultat qu'on a et la qualité du
parcours qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est le
résultat de quatre ans de travail en
groupe et c'est pas moins que ça le
parcours eu d'extraordinaire mais les
retours qu'on peut avoir des joueurs
c'est que
c'est un parcours qui est largement est
largement au niveau d'accueillir un
événement aussi important qu'une ryder
cup
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission
spéciale à ryder cup rendez vous demain
pour de nouvelles aventures 10 il a
passé une excellente soirée golfique
[Musique]
oh
m